10,90. Il y en aura au moins 60
abattue et le plus vite
possible, nous dit la mairesse.
Les cerfs du parc à Longueuil.
Madame la mairesse, bonjour.
- Bonjour.
- C'est réglé. Vous allez devoir
effectivement les abattre en
euthanasie. Vous avez un rapport
qui vous a été déposé.
C'est un dossier réglé. Comment
vous comprenez la solution?
Qu'est-ce qu'il va arriver?
CATHERINE FOURNIER,
mairesse de Longueuil
- Bien, d'abord, c'est important
de remettre les solutions
dans le processus. Ce qu'on va
dévoiler demain matin, ce qui va
êtrblic sur le site
Web de la Ville de Longueuil
à 7 h, c'est le rapport de la
table de concertation, qui a été
mise en place il y a quelques
mois, c'est une table qui a
réuni des citoyens, des experts,
des scientifiques,
qui a consulté une revue
de littérature scientifique
s imposante, qui a également
entendu différent groupes.
Toutes, toutes, toutes les
possibilités ont été analysées
pour assurer l'équilibre
écologique du parc Michel-
Chartrand. Et c'est vraiment ça
qui est au coeur du message de
la table de recommandations...
de la table de concertation,
pardon. Donc, ce sont
des recommandations qui vont
nous permettre d'agir sur les
trois facteurs qui expliquent
pourquoi les milieux naturels se
sont dégradés au point qu'
parviennent plus à se régénérer
ici dans le parc. Parce que
c'est ça, l'enjeu, actuellement.
Il y a des effets dévastateurs
de l'agrile du frêne. Il y a
la propagation des espèces
exotiques envahissantes,
notamment en raison
des changements climatiques.
Et finalement, i
l'alimentation des cerfs de
Virginie, qui sont actuellement
minimalement cinq fois plus
nombreux que ce que peut
souten Michel-
Chartrand. Donc, c'est clair
qu'il y a des solutions de
réduction du cheptel qui vont
devoir être entreprises.
- Il y en a... i en a... i en aà
peu près, des cerfs. D'ailleurs,
il y en a un juste là. En tout
cas. Il n'a pas peur, il n'est
pas peureux. Il y en a à peu
s 70. Le parc peut en faire
vivre une dizaine. Donc,
il arrive quoi aux 60 autres?
Vous allez devoir les abattre?
- Il va devoir y avoir
des solutions à court et à long
terme. Parce qu'on sait qu
si on réduit le cheptel, bien,
dans les prochaines années,
ça risque d'augmenter. Donc,
il va falloir que, vraiment,
des mesures qui soient mises en
place. Notamment, on va analyser
la question de la stérilisation.
Mais pour ce qui est de
maintenant, effectivement,
on va devoir prendre des actions
pour réduire immédiatement
le cheptel. Donc, la capture,
l'euthanasie, et par la suite,
d'offrir la viande à des
organismes communautaires, donc,
qui va permettre de valoriser
les cete façon-là.
- Ce qui devait être fait...
Je veux dire, tout ça pour ça,
ce qui devait être fait.
Il y a eu des gens qui s'y sont
s. Et on rs. Et on rs. Et on rse
qu'on avait décidé, finalement.
- En fait, c'est le processus
qui est important. Moi, je pense
que c'est intéressant qu'on ait
pu entendre différents groupes,
qu'on s'assure vraiment que
toutes les solutions ont été
analysées. Parce que l'année
dernière, ça n'avait pas été
communiqué de cette façon-là.
Il n'y avait pas nécessairement
le travail en amont qui avait
été fait. Donc là, on s
assurés que... est-ce que
le déplacement était possible?
Malheureusement, non,
pour les effets de stress,
pour les effets également
de la maladie de Lyme, qui est
très présente ici dans
la région, qu'on ne veut pas
er dans d'er dans d'er dans d'e.
Et en fait, pourquoi l'urgence
est encore plus grande,
c'est qu'on voit que les cerfs,
actuellement, sont dans
nditions de vie vraiment
déplorables. Ils sont sous-
alimentés. Puis, le nombre
a vraiment explosé, même dans la
dernière année, parce que c'est,
à chaque année avec la période
de gestation et la mise à bas
qui a eu lieu au printemps.
Donc, on serait même plutôtprès
à l'heure actuelle. Donc, d'oùr.
Nous, on va avoir besoin
de la collaboration du ministère
de la Faune et des Parcs dans
le dossier parce qu'on va avoire
plus on attend, malheureusement,
plus il va y avoir
un cheptel important.
- Idéalement, vous commenceriez?
C'est à l'automne, au printemps?
- Ça va devoir être analysé,
notamment avec le comité
d'éthique de l'Université de
Montréal. Nous, on ne fera rien
sans avoir leur aval,
leur approbation. C'est très
important de bien faire
les choses. On sait que c'est un
dossier sensible. On veut qu'il
y ait le moins de souffrance
animale possible. C'est pour ça
également que toutes
les solutions ont été étudiées.
On va prendre le temps
de bien faire les choses avec
des vétérinaires également,
des scientifiques qui vont nous
accompagner dans le processus.
Donc, une fois qu'on a obtenu
le certificat de bons soins de
la part du comité d'éthique,
on va pouvoir avoir les permis
du MFFP, et ça va nous permettre
de procéder. Mais évidemment, on
souhaiterait que ce soit le plus
rapidement possible parce que
si on reporte d'une année, bien,
malheureusement, le cheptel va
être encore plus grand. Et c'est
certain que ça va devoir être
une opération plus importante.
- Mais je répète, si on avait
procédé alors qu'on voulai
le faire, le problème aurait été
réglé. C'est comme si
on a repoussé le problème.
- En fait, c'est que c'est un...
ce n'est pas seu
des cerfs. Et je pense que c'est
ça que la table a voulu mettre
de l'avant également. Il y a
plusieurs enjeux qui affectent
l'état des milieux naturels ici
dans le parc Michel-Chartrand.
Les cerfs, c'est effectivement
la première voie de passage,
disons, qu'il faut régler pour
s'attaquer aux autres problèmes,
sans quoi on ne sera pas capable
de le faire. Mais néanmoins,
on considère que le travail
qui a été réalisé par la table
de concertation, il a été
important. Je pense qu'il va
même faire des petits à travers
le Québec, comment on gère
une situation comme ça,
délicate, je pense que ça
être modèle innovateur qui va
inspirer d'autres villes de
la région qui sont aux prises
avec les mêmes problèmes.AN TAB,
district Parc-Michel-Chartrand
- Parce que l'enjeu est le même
dans tous les grands parcs
de la Montérégie. Donc, il y aue
aux changements climatiques,
mais due aussi au changement de
nos habitudes, on... Les gens
nourrissent les cerfs un petitps
années. Donc, ce que Longueuil
est en train de faire ici,
c'est précurseur pour
l'ensemble, finalement, de la
région. Et on sait que d'autres
villes qui attendent le rapport.
Et cette fois-ci, la table de
concertation a analysé toutes
les avenues possibles. Donc, on
sait qu'il y avait eu un travail
qui avait été fait en amont
au cours des dernières années.
Par contre, cette fois-ci,
tout est bien documenté et
sera disponible pour le public.
- Et s'il y a une levée de
boucliers, vous faites quoi,
Madame la mairesse? Si ça y est,
les gens qui aiment les an
et avec des bons sentiments,
viennent vous dire : "Vous ne
pouvez pas tuer les chevreuils",
vous faites quoi?
- Bien, nous aus
les animaux. Mais justement, il
n'y a pas seulement les cerfs.
Et la fs,
ça affecte également les autres
espèces et l'écosystème, en
fait, du parc Michel-Chartrand.
Donc, nous, notre position,
s claire depuis
le départ : on veut se fier sur
la séance. Un processus qui a
été fait de façon indépendante,
qui sera transparent également,
les recommandations seront
disponibles au public.
Donc, nous, on va suivre
les recommandations. Si on veute
accessible pour les citoyens et
les citoyennes non seulement de
Longueuil, mais aussi de toute
la région, parce que c'estun paa
des décisions qui s'imposent.
Ce n'est pas des décisions qui
sont faciles, mais on va devoir
maintenir le cap.- Et il n'y a t
ça ici de gaieté de coeur. C'est
fait parce que c'est la seule
avenue possible, c'est la seule
option viable à long terme et
à court terme dans l'écosystème.
Et je peux vous dire, en tant
que conseiller municipal
du district ici, l'opinion
populaire a énormément évoluée.
Donc, au courant de la dernière
opération, il y avait une large
opposition, finalement,
aux façons de faire parce que
l'information n'avait pas
transmise, finalement,
à l'ensemble de la population.
Et je peux vous confirmer
qu'au cours des derniers mois,
c'est l'inverse qui est en
d'arriver.
- Très bien. Merci beaucoup
pour ces précisions. Merci.
- Merc